I bumped into you when we were doing
Comic Con I saw you in a restaurant and
you're with your family and it's
interesting because you clearly this
isn't a persona that you have for your
comedy work or foreign appearance and
then oh now I'm with my kids you don't
change it all for your kids no no no no
as a matter of fact we were in Bali on a
vacation we went to this monkey jungle
and they're like hey just heads up
monkeys sometimes hump you and and I
told my daughters right away I go hey if
you're getting humped by a monkey do not
expect me to help you out I will be
filming it in landscape mode and if I
get humped by a monkey do not help me
film it in landscape mode flip it around
yourself and go body shots world tour
and then flip it back around yeah
neither was on her period so we were
like praying we're like please have a
monkey sniffer out me like
I think you should change a little bit
around I was praying for a monkey to
help my daughter you realize how many
tickets that what it sold on that
alright let my god you're a monster
you're a soulless monster you know
listen there's it you this is this a
real I'm we have a picture here of a bar
mitzva right is whose Bar Mitzvah is
this is Carter Gruesomes Bar Mitzvah
just say he's a friend of my kids
Carter crews informants what's his
telephone number yeah I got it I saved
it under gay escort service in my phone
if he ever calls it comes up gay escort
service and was like whoa and I go don't
worry it's Carter
we have a picture of you at this kids
Bar Mitzvah and you're you're I think
we've the picture right here and your
daughter is in the background
yeah that's Carter's dad Eric and then
that's Georgia
my oldest daughter just unhappy thing I
think he's going I'm so lucky
Oh like you know like going oh you know
how they do all in the slam dunk contest
oh [ __ ] son oh pretty girl so when
they're proud they usually cover their
face I'm so proud of this moment